and michael gave
we now understand
told the prime minister he was unhappy
for him
to carry on
and as i understand it no resignation
for michael gove at the moment so at the
moment doing some heavy lifting there's
that you get the sense that more cabinet
resignations could come if the prime
minister
doesn't
stand down and then all the while you've
then got
the 22 committee meeting later today is
running at a pace and
we were talking last night about the
kind of moment of those two bombshell
resignations if we go back to that
moment that that really was the moment
where this civil war
uh in the conservative party over boris
johnson really blew open again and i
think as you get to the end stages of
that fighting it's getting very ugly and
it gets very brutal because boris
johnson's fighting for his life and
there are you know his political life
and then there are a number of people
that would want him gone and i think
that's why it's getting so
visceral and nasty right at this moment
because it's always like this in the
final tussles